[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la Jaguar à l'Aston Martin le musée
Matra a troqué le drapeau tricolore pour
celui de l'Union Jack dans les allées
des modèles anglais mythiques comme
cette Rolls-Royce Phantom de 1928 déjà
très moderne pour son temps le
propriétaire pouvait parler à travers
l'interphone jusqu'à devant avec le
chauffeur quand la vitre était fermée il
y avait différents compartiments pour
mettre des choses et des lumières
séparées pour la lecture
et puis une ambiance salon anglais
très british
17 modèles sont présentés parmi eux
celui-ci pièce maîtresse de l'exposition
prêté par un particulier il n'en existe
que trois au monde les deux autres sont
aux Émirats Arabes Unis c'est une
McLaren de
que Bruce McLaren célèbre pilote en 66
voulait mettre en série ils ont fait
trois et au mois de juin 70 Bruce
McLaren s'est tué en course au circuit
de Bollywood en Angleterre
[Musique]
des années 1920 aux années 80 ces
voitures de collection ont traversé le
temps et forger le mythe de la voiture
anglaise en termes de design je pense
qu'il y a une petite patte anglaise qui
est quand même pas désagréable qui vaut
peut-être passer des italiens mais voilà
donc il y a comme des magnifiques
voitures magnifiques voitures moi je la
trouve super bonne voilà
vous seriez acheteurs
le musée Matra sera alors anglaise
jusqu'au 12 novembre